الوثائق المسربه من البانتاجون تكشف
معطيات صادمه
توقل امريكي كبير في الجهاز العسكري
الروسي والاوكراني
الوثائق اظهرت قدره واشنطن على تحذير
اوكرانيا بشان الضربات المخطط لها من
روسيا وتقييم اله الحرب الروسيه
الوثائق ترسم صوره للجيش الروسي المتهاوي
الذي يكافح في حرب اوكرانيا
وتكشف نقل المعلومات الحساسه للدفاع عن
نفسها من خلال تحديد توقيت الضربات
واهدافها
الوثائق تظهر ان عملاء واشنطن يخترقون
تقريبا كل الاجهزه الامنيه الروسيه
مسؤول استخباراتي غربي قال ان التسريب
مؤلم وقد يحد من تبادل المعلومات
الاستخباراتيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات